there  well it's been over a calendar year  since these two teams met  we've got a lot of drawing going on the  front row  and uh look at that and now the uh  security is getting involved and the  security is actually  i mean the referees are actually telling  the security they may want to  usher somebody uh to the out of the  building they might be gone i think this  was happening also  somebody was all over lebron they're  still on lebron i think that's what it  is a few minutes ago and i know he was  glaring into the seats  i i think lebron obviously you can see  he's not  that upset about it i think it's nothing  now yeah  they're not kicking them out it's just  any fans ever  remember it was that uh executive of the  cavaliers that  set lebron off in cleveland  this lady wow  where she's pointing like that one meme  with the lady and the cat  yeah okay  oh boy you gotta love it 86-78  we'll